hello minimizers you are in for a treat
this week you're about to hear a
conversation between the minimalists and
our good friend ken coleman
unfortunately we had an accident and we
lost the video version of the podcast
but fear not we still have perfect audio
so enjoy this conversation between the
minimalists and ken coleman
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists does the work you do
matter to you or do you just do it for a
paycheck no matter where you are in your
career today's guest says you were born
to do work you love of course there's
nothing wrong with working to earn a
paycheck but if you work only to make
money you'll eventually feel unfulfilled
overwhelmed and creatively drained
thankfully you don't have to choose
between making an income and making an
impact today we are joined by the author
of the new book from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
our friend ken coleman is here ladies
and gentlemen yeah oh man this is so
exciting
i'm here in l.a gorgeous studio by the
way oh beautiful thank you so much we
have so much to talk about today on this
public version we're going to talk well
about purposeful work we're going to
talk about your new book
i want to dive deep into that on the
maximal as well we're going to talk
about on the maximum i want to talk to
you about the great resignation i know
it's something you've been grappling
with on your own show the ken coleman
show which we'll put a link to in the
show notes folks can check that out but
also we're going to talk about burnout
at work on the the private maximal
episode this week and we're going to
talk about working from home how this is
sort of shifting we're gonna talk about
quitting your job we're gonna talk about
changing careers completely and a bunch
of questions about finding meaningful
work but ken as you know this show is a
listener driven show so let's dive in
laura from patreon has a question for us
what does purpose even mean
it seems we are expected to have one but
what if you're okay with not having a
purpose at work
ken i i like to start with this question
because i
i get where laura's coming from i sort
of have an allergy to this word
and not the way that you explain it but
the way that it's often used in the
culture as though you were born to do
only one thing that's right and if you
don't if you were born to be an
astronaut and you don't become an
astronaut then everything else you do is
meaningless that doesn't seem to me that
what you're talking about when you're
talking about purpose no we're not
talking about a title
we're not talking about a profession
what we're talking about is a
contribution and i love the question too
and you can hear the search in the
question the very context by which that
question is asked says she hasn't quite
figured out
what that unique contribution is for her
and so as you know when i break down
purpose i look at the three elements
that every human being brings to the
world talent
skills hello
hard skills people skills and then we
look at passion that's love
love
of a craft i i'm an old school history
nerd
and uh because my parents couldn't
afford it we would go to all these older
historical homes on vacations when i was
a kid and they would always have a
blacksmith i mean a real blacksmith a
silversmith you know
someone a cobbler making shoes and when
you look at somebody like that who is a
true craftsman
they loved
the work of
creating and formulating something that
was usable so passion speaks to i just
love the work whether it's painting
something like this behind me
or it is
coding and creating an app or a website
so that's passion and then finally you
know that it all comes together when we
see the contribution
from our work we go i'm
making a shoe
right to allow someone to be able to
just functionally walk comfortably right
yes now everybody but ryan needs a shoe
all right but uh but you know so so when
we see the result of our work that's
mission so when talent passion and
mission intersect for this lady it's
like oh it doesn't matter the job title
it doesn't matter the profession what
matters is the contribution and i would
say
all of us have purpose
because we're not an accident yes so
that's how i look at purpose so when i
look at this ryan tell me if you agree
with this and and ken i'd love to hear
your thoughts but it seems to me that
what we're saying here is that all of us
are driven to do something that matters
something that matters to you something
that matters to other people but
something that matters to us yes as well
and i think that's really important we
are compelled to create to communicate
to express ourselves compelled to do
something significant and
what is so compelling that you want to
devote your life to it maybe that's a
different way to look at purpose because
i get it sometimes people would say well
yeah find your purpose or follow your
passion that's not what you're saying
here what you're saying is if there is
something that is so compelling to you
something that matters to you so much
then you can devote your life to it not
confusing it for excitement but actually
understanding there is something many
things in fact that you can be
passionate about something that will
serve the greater good so what gives you
energy yeah what makes you feel most
alive i'm reading this book by jonathan
franzen right now and there was this
line that i wrote down about this woman
who had just discovered theater
alabama will know about this she became
a different person in rehearsals entered
a kind of trance of not her selfness
i mean how beautiful is that what is the
thing for you
that enters you into a trance of not
your selfness it makes that clock time
just go by it does weird things with
time that's what you're talking about
with craft oh yeah and so let's take
that that's a wonderful quote and and i
understand what the writer is saying
there but the not yourselfness but
what's funny is is that's your ultimate
selfness bingo
and you know what it is it's a
metamorphosis okay and i don't know much
about science history's my game
but when
that butterfly finally emerges from the
cocoon that's what the writer was
talking about there i remember years ago
when american idol was just kind of
coming on the scene i'll never forget uh
they had reached the finals and some
little gal walked out a little petite
gown you could just see it all over very
very shy you could see she was timid and
they hadn't shown her in all of the
preliminaries because she probably
wasn't a wacky person yet she was wildly
talented and i'll never forget as the
music started and she hit her first note
within about 15 seconds what was this
and it's a terrifying moment to perform
in front of millions and millions of
people on that stage in front of simon
cowell and yet in 30 seconds she went
through a complete
physical transformation you could see it
on her and so i think it's the highest
version of self yes you know masloff
talked about self-actualization
that's what i'm talking about i'm
talking about purpose in that there is
something unique that you have to give
to the world now i am translating it to
work because i want you to experience
that in your work
right because it is possible the
alternative is what doing something you
dislike for 40 hours a week so that you
can do the other thing and it's not
there's anything wrong with that for a
period of time as i talked about in the
intro yes we have to earn a paycheck but
when that becomes the primary driver of
doing everything we do we often lose
that sense of purpose that's absolutely
right yeah i think with laura's question
it sounds like to me that she has a job
at j-o-b sure she shows up she gets paid
and she goes home and she's okay with
that and i think there is like this
societal pressure for people to be like
well you've got to have this you know
this this mission this purpose at your
job and you know what if you just have a
job and you're okay with that that's
fine
that's that's not a problem at all it's
like minimalism minimalism is a great
answer it can work for anyone but it's
not for everyone but i'm willing to bet
that there's something outside of her
job that that that job allows her to do
with her time with her finances yeah you
know something comes to mind i want to
share it's in the book i write the story
of martin luther king jr who accepted an
opportunity to speak this is the guy's
at the height of his influence
and obviously a marked man and he gets
an invite to speak to some middle school
students and he comes in and you can
find grainy versions of this on youtube
and it's amazing and he's known for his
speech in washington i have a dream he's
known for you know i've been to the
mountain the night before he was
tragically murdered in memphis he's
known for those two speeches but it is
this speech that i have fallen in love
with and it speaks to the question
um and so i'm setting the scene and so
at the heart of this question
she's going
i don't want to be a big deal and that's
what purpose
has been
adulterated into it's been it's been
hijacked and it's like we hear purpose
and we think and that's what your
allergy is
it just came to me i never heard anybody
say that and i was i was processing now
now here it is and then i'm going to go
back to the middle school scene
here's the deal we hear purpose and we
think lofty and we think big and
impressive and lots of followers and
likes and salary and all the things
and martin luther king put it best he's
looking at those middle school students
and he says to them i'm paraphrasing you
can get it in the book and read the
whole excerpt go watch it he says don't
let anybody ever rob you of your
somebodiness
[Music]
yes and then he says and you've all read
this this is the part where he says
if it is your lot
to sweep streets
then sweep streets
like michelangelo painted yeah i mean
i'm getting goosebumps right now i get a
little chokey
because he says sweep streets as though
all the hosts of heaven were watching
you and they say there live the greatest
street sweeper the world has ever seen
um it takes me to a story that i shared
on the ken coleman show years ago about
a
a janitor in a high school who had been
a janitor for a long time she'd always
just love orderliness and she was the
janitor she was the first one there and
it was a cold it was in the northeast it
was a cold winter morning and she had
just opened up the school she was in the
cafeteria turning the lights on and she
heard a bang at the door she went to
open up the door
and there stood two teens
and they were living in their car with
their mom their moms working two and
three jobs just to take care of them
they're living in the car and because
she had to get to an early shift
she dropped them off and she said bang
on the door and they did and the janitor
let them in
she then began to hear their story and
i'll fast forward and she realized that
they were in fact homeless and that day
she took a list from them of the things
they needed basic toiletries blankets
coats and she went from her own house
and friends and she gathered the items
for those kids and when she gave them to
the kids she saw the reaction you know
what she did that day she cleaned out
one of her janitor closets and turned it
into a free store wow and now for years
decades she has taken donations from the
community and she's a hero in that
school and the amount of lives that that
woman has changed
i love it yeah i love it so that's some
bloodiness and see there's there's
purpose in the janitorial work too it's
not the big lofty things it's your
little things
and the your part is so key because i
think about beulah who painted all these
beautiful paintings are behind us by the
way goldmorning.com if you want to check
it out yes her stuff she's absolutely
stunning now what she does here i
couldn't do it if i was forced to do it
it wouldn't be me right and if she was
forced to do the things that i do it
wouldn't be her it was about identifying
the thing that gives her that
somebody-ness that aliveness that thing
that makes her feel
so alive and compelled something to
devote yourself to that's what we're
talking about here today i love your
story ken cause basically it says hey no
matter what job you have you can find a
way to contribute beyond yourself in a
meaningful way and that's really uh yeah
josh and i that's part of our message is
find a way to contribute what i love
about the martin luther king story is
he's giving you permission to make your
work art yes with anything that you have
yes and you know it's interesting
because i i think back to when i was
driving from dayton ohio to cincinnati
on on that stretch of 75 and like i'd
always get stuck in traffic
and i remember just sitting there
thinking man i don't want to work for
this company anymore and like i was kind
of in this really stuck position and i
kept asking like you know kind of
praying meditating asking like i just
want to find something where i can
contribute beyond myself in a meaningful
way like i don't care how much money i
make i don't care what i do what i do
but as long as i can contribute like
that's what really matters and fast
forward now you know 10 11 years later
what i've really come to realize
is that no matter what job you have
you are contributing to someone in some
way whether it's like the clerk at
mcdonald's or whether it's the waitress
or whether it's the janitor there is a
service that is happening and i think
this is your uh kind of your advice is
you know figure out how you want to help
people and like help that guide you
towards a career yeah yeah it's
two-sided so we i know we went out here
but i really wanted to dive into this
because i think this question represents
a lot of people yeah that have
resistance to even my message they're
like okay dude i'm not interested in
being a big shot but you are a big deal
but big deal has nothing to do with how
many people know your name right big
deal has everything to do with that
janitor coming into the lives of those
kids
that was the big deal you are a big deal
to somebody if you are in customer care
right now and you just love it or you go
i just want to be a receptionist there's
purpose in that yes there's tremendous
purpose in that and i think that we've
got to get beyond
um
putting someone else's expectations into
our purpose it's two-sided and i love
the story i-75 i'm never gonna forget
that
because purpose is two-sided it is the
contribution to others but it's the
contribution that we want to make to
others that's right i'll just tell you
i started out on sports radio i love
sports to this day i'll talk sports all
day long but i learned pretty quickly
that that wasn't purposeful for me right
um i now am in the growth space right
i'm in the purpose space i want to
broadcast to transform i was
broadcasting to entertain nothing wrong
with that no in fact but for me that's
my purpose does that make sense
absolutely yeah you enjoyed the thing
but just because you enjoy something
there's nothing wrong with pleasure and
enjoying it it doesn't necessarily mean
that you're going to find it to be a
meaningful activity beautifully said
yeah that's it meaning
meaning and purpose you can't
extrapolate the two yeah that's that's
purpose what what's the meaning you want
to experience because here's the great
news once you experience that meaning
there's always a person on the other
side of it as you beautifully
illustrated so i'm going to talk to you
about writing a purpose statement here
in a bit because well in fact we'll
probably talk about that on the maximal
episode but we have a question here from
clayton in newport kentucky where ryan
and i have spent a lot of days
isn't that just like south cincinnati
yeah it's just the other side of the
road is it like the newport and the oc
as well or very different
it's just right across the river
cincinnati ohio
there's no accident there's no kentucky
accent on that side actually there is
that's i had people who worked
who would come across the river and you
knew everyone who was from kentucky
because for whatever reason that
kentucky accident it just
as soon as you cross the river the
accent changes anyway clayton what do
you got to say to us i really just want
to live
more meaningful and i want to travel the
world and i really just want to get a
van and just go places but i'm wondering
what would be a good option for making
money while doing that how would i
follow my passion while making money
doing it because i can't just go on the
road with no money but as that seems
like the only option i'm wondering if i
could just ask you guys if you have any
advice or tips
on doing that because i really feel like
my passion is traveling and
i just want to see the world
so ken clayton here he wants to get a
van travel the country but also oh my
god how do i make money
people call into your show all the time
with questions like this what do you
tell someone like clayton well now this
is a fun question because clayton's
going i see great passion in the
traveling and experiencing things right
he's going but i got to make a living
and so what we do here is we're going to
get super practical first and then we'll
get into the passion so on the practical
side we go okay let's just look at
talent all right what do you do really
really well and you know what for for a
guy like clayton 2021
2022 2023 and beyond this is the perfect
time to actually live this life amen
because of technology and you can work
from anywhere
um and so i think there's two approaches
i would be brainstorming the first is
okay i'm gonna look at what i do best so
we're gonna look at all of your talent
and skills that you've developed over
time and then we're gonna look at your
experience and so those come together as
this awesome tool belt all right so
clayton's got this tool belt and he's
going okay i can make money with these
things so how do i make money with these
things
from anywhere yeah that's where we would
start the brainstorm so if i had a
whiteboard i go okay let's look at all
this and we go okay where can i make
that online where it doesn't matter if
you're in nebraska one day wisconsin the
next as long as you've got a signal you
can check in so we're gonna look at that
okay so with that you start
brainstorming that stuff clayton you're
gonna have to be patient because it
might be that this is a two to three
maybe a five year process of setting up
that online business or developing that
remote work that you can do for anybody
anywhere and then that gets you to a
place where it's developed enough to win
now i can go on the road so be patient
in this it may not be i can go start
this tomorrow now the other brainstorm
idea
i don't want you guys to jump in on this
one
uh
is how does he combine the travel
where i'm traveling to work right so
he's so i'm going you know i i bet you
clayton wants to travel the world too i
don't hear just the continental 48
states here i
and so i go well is there a is there a
connection between the people you most
want to help and the problem you want to
solve and traveling right yeah because
if it's hey i'm going to work for a
non-profit or i'm going to work for a
global organization and it requires me
to be on the move every three to four
months well that might just be his jam
because he's going to get the travel but
he's also going to get the contribution
so that's the framework i would start
with for somebody like this yeah
absolutely i like how you talked about
uh
it it might take two to five years it
might
there's something interesting about the
human psyche where
we can't like when we think about the
next 30 days and how much we can get
done we usually overestimate how much we
can get done yeah but we underestimate
like what we can get done in you know
one to two years and i remember uh the
story in your book about from you know
the day that you told your wife like hey
we are i'm going a different route i'm
going to do something else it was eight
years yeah eight years for you for you
to come to fruition with what you're
doing now
and i just think that's such an
important part because i think that uh
clayton here can totally travel and work
but it is gonna take a little bit of
time and you know as far as the
traveling goes i love that idea like i
so i was a really good salesman and if
traveling was the most important thing
for me yeah i would totally look at it
traveling in fact love that idea i have
this like i have this uh
this this dream of one day with our uh
our coffee company bandit yeah like
going around from city to city and like
just having different coffee shops try
our coffee and like basically selling
coffee on the road so i've got traveling
which i would love to do and i really
really love coffee so it's like those
two things mixed together is that's kind
of the sweet spot come home yeah i think
it's very possible let's talk about
where minimalism comes into this
minimalism with respect to finances
first off right so if you really want to
do something what is preventing you from
doing that thing quite often it's like
oh my god i've got so much debt now
we've talked plenty about debt and you
all know
dave ramsey and the baby steps and all
that stuff and uh you obviously talk
about it quite a bit on on his show and
on your show as well
being tethered to a lifestyle right now
that is preventing you from doing what
you want to do that is a barrier now
where does minimalism help it helps you
identify what is essential what is
non-essential but adds value to your
life and then what's junk we call that
the no junk rule by the way so
everything you own and also everything
you spend your money on can fit in one
of those three categories it's either
essential we all have the same
essentials clothing food shelter
transportation etc and then we have
different non-essentials these are the
things we don't absolutely need but they
add some value to our lives i don't
absolutely have to have a kitchen table
but i'm not going to deprive myself
however clayton you may have to
temporarily deprive yourself of some of
these value-adding non-essentials so
that you can move in the direction in
which you want to go because it's worth
more to you to pursue that dream to
pursue that thing that will
give you meaning or purpose in life you
might have to let go of some of those
things that are getting in the way even
though they they feel like they're
adding value right now and then of
course anything that's junk we want to
get rid of we're spending all of our
money and all this junk to impress a
bunch of people that are preventing us
from doing what we want to do yeah i'm
going to say yes and amen but i'm going
to go a step further i don't think might
is the is the word he's going to have to
give something up yes i'm just telling
you yeah i'm just telling you uh one of
my mentors john maxwell i worked for for
years he said it so famously you're
going to have to give up something to go
up you got to give up to go up you just
got to choose what you're giving up and
absolutely minimalism what i love about
you guys is it's a way of thinking it's
a way of living it's a philosophy
and it absolutely comes in here to this
purpose conversation at some point
you're going to have to choose you're
going to have to give something up and
you got to decide what matters most yeah
absolutely well clayton i know you're in
the travel if you want to travel 100
miles north up i-71
we have a event in columbus it's either
in january or february we're coming to
11 more cities with the love people use
things tor will be in new york and
boston
and washington dc and chicago and
toronto and chicago and columbus and l.a
and san francisco seattle vancouver and
a couple other cities the
minimalists.com tour to find a city near
you but clayton we'll send you a couple
tickets to that event hop in your van
your car or i love that just throw your
thumb out can i challenge clayton you
need to do this take the tickets man go
to columbus and these guys take q and a
brainstorm it right then and there yeah
get the audience in on it let's do it
we'll have a dream we'd have a dream for
clayton in about 30 seconds he needs to
come to that event we'll see you up
there aboutminimalists.com tour to find
a city near you ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it's time for the
lending round where we answer your text
messages you can text your questions and
comments to area code
937-202-4654 now can you remember from
previous episodes what ryan and our
guest and i do is we answer questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response whoa we call them
here we go we call them minimal maxims
and we like that podcast sean over there
he he he makes him pretty he cleans up
my semicolons and stuff
and he puts them in the show notes so
people can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media and our good
friend jessica she puts all of these
minimal maxims in one place over at
minimalmaxims.com so you can find all of
these little pithy sayings but ken as
you know we just ramble and monder on a
bit until we find something beautiful to
tweet we have a question here from
stephen
i just turned 40. i have an amazing wife
and a three-year-old son
how do i make the choice to follow a
purpose when there are bills to pay and
family responsibilities to be fulfilled
so
i think it's
key and you certainly talk about this
ken it's key to not confuse
work as being the only thing that is
meaningful in our lives right or even
money be money is simply a tool and it
can aid it can amplify whatever we're
doing but it is not the meaning of
anything that we do and so here's my
pithy answer for you maybe we can unpack
it together human worth is not
determined by net worth
and so
you were already worthy
i think this question quite often
presupposes i either need to choose
paycheck
or purpose
but that's not right no no my pithy
answer is
do what you have to do
so that later you can do what you want
to do
there's a false narrative in the
question
that i have to choose providing for my
wife and child or children
and doing what i was created to do false
choice i write about in the book you can
read it
it took me five to seven years to even
get a decent break seven and a half
years to finally step into ramsey
solutions i supported my three kids my
wife and the two dogs
through that so it is not a either or
it's both in but the both end requires
that you do what you have to do
financially you get qualified on the
side you dabble you test you be patient
and for goodness sake don't quit and
then eventually you'll have both yeah
yeah it's like sometimes you have to
have a side hustle before you had your
full hustle
i mean there it is that boy boy i was
trying to be pithy that was perfect but
i gotta i gotta get that podcast on yeah
i got a i got another pithy answer a
paycheck will help you survive but a
purpose will help you thrive oh man he's
two for two and you know it's in your
book you actually bring up this exact um
i want to call it an excuse because it
is an excuse it is or this like
self-limiting belief and i think in that
chapter what you talk about is helping
someone get focused on what that that
dream job or that purposeful job looks
like and right now it sounds like steven
lacks a little bit of focus oh yeah and
what i love about your book man is it's
just such practical advice from
literally being in a job you hate doing
things that that you you know you wake
up every single day and you don't look
forward to going to work and you have
this very very
good formulation really of how to really
find someone's purpose how to get
focused and
eventually how to get that that job that
is purposeful yeah you know i love i'm
fascinated by great mountain climbers
and as you know i write about adam and
hillary in the book but you know i've
watched all these documentaries on
amazon prime about mount everest and i
can tell you this
these folks aren't focused on how cold
it is
or how windy it is
no or how sore they are right because if
they do they die
and so he's looking at all this
he needs to be looking up here
and if i'm here and i'm focused on
getting here this will all take care of
itself what you're talking about is
we're so afraid of losing comfort yes
and it's that comfort that is actually
killing us
tweet that podcast
yeah i gotta step you guys are bringing
it today so so i do want to talk to you
about clarity for stephen because you
talk a lot about clarity in the book and
what does that mean because it seems to
me right right now that that the comfort
is actually getting in the way of his
clarity oh
and see comfort oh it's it's a killer
it's a dream killer
because comfort lulls us into this idea
that well i'm being smart mm-hmm
i you know and well i didn't i didn't
pursue it because um and this is the
thought we have by ourselves it was
reckless for me to do that i had kids
my responsibility yeah i had a wife and
kids i had to put the kid in school and
so therefore i was doing the right thing
i was selfless
in letting my dream die that's a big
bunch of freaking garbage i sacrificed
my dreams so comfort comes in and goes
well i have to this is nice if i do this
and if we sell our house
which we can make a ton of money on and
i fund the training that i need and we
all cram into a three little three
bedroom eighteen hundred square foot
cottage as opposed to the five bedroom 3
500 4 000 foot thick and what are the
kids going to think i think dad's a
loser i mean i'm talking real stuff
right here yeah okay and so we we talk
ourselves into well
safe smart and i got to tell you
something all great women and great men
people who did great things whether we
know their name or not
at some point embraced discomfort
absolutely they embraced the unknown and
this young man i love the question i get
he's 40. he's a young man
he's worried about discomfort he's
worried about the unknown and here's the
deal you can worry about that all you
want to and you're going to end up at
the end of your days like teddy
roosevelt said in his famous man in the
arena speech a cold and timid soul who
knew neither victory nor defeat
yeah
that's not how i want to end up
yeah like i can tell you i'm so blessed
to know you guys
i hope we're all old men together and
like we're here in la or nashville and
we're just kind of talking and we're
going to look back i hope in a little
bit of laughter and a little bit of
tears as we look back on the
contribution we were able to make and we
reminisce not regret i don't want to be
a crotchety old fart who's just like
well i could have done this but i got
screwed and this condition is yeah like
i don't i don't that's not who we're
meant to be i want to look back and go i
failed spectacularly
as i write about in the book but i i was
able to do something that meant
something to me and i can look and say i
helped a few people that's right
ken we got so much more to talk about
but emma you got something for us first
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hi my name is becca i'm from columbus
ohio i'm calling with a tip
for tracy who um commented in the
episode about organization that her
pantry was getting out of hand again and
this is a problem i have had also
i've gotten it down to a system
i i discovered that part of the reason
my pantry was getting out of panda is
because i like adventures in food
so now i have my pantry organized by
type
for me that you know that means i have a
shelf for beans for greens for for
grains another shelf for nuts you know
everything by type but then i have a
special area in my pantry for
adventures uh like i like to bake so i
have a lot of flowers and there's a
whole section just for
different and interesting gluten-free
flours like mesquite flour and coconut
flour and then when that section gets
full i know my mom i put myself on a
little bit of a ban so one time
my chocolate
shelf got really full so i was on a
chocolate buying ban until i used up my
chocolate i've also had a t-vine ban
just to help me really focus on enjoying
those items that i have acquired and
purchased so i hope that is helpful tip
for you
just to help keep yourself in check with
new and interesting foods thanks
hello this is lynn from south africa
i've got it for those people that are
looking through um perhaps nostalgic
paperwork i'm looking through my
daughter's baby boxes now and seeing to
keep them what to
to toss and a good idea would actually
just to listen to the podcast while you
sorting through um it can be quite a
emotional time and you get wrapped up
maybe in your old thoughts and memories
um and then just to kind of bring
clarification again it's quite fast to
be listening to the podcast and saying
and reminding yourself why are you doing
this so that's my suggestion all right
y'all before we get into our added value
segment this week which i think you're
going to enjoy let's give a big thanks
to ken coleman for joining us today you
can check out his new book it's called
from paycheck to purpose heck yeah man i
really wish that
that book was available to me in my
corporate days because it's just such a
it's a great
um just formula i said it earlier it's a
formula on how to go from like hating
your job to like getting a clear path
forward to getting a job that really
means something um we did it the hard
way
instead of having a nice formula for it
yeah you know what i really dig about
ken by the way you can check out his
website we'll put a link to that in the
show notes he has a career assessment
thing on his website as well he also has
a show the ken coleman show which you
can check out plus he'll be joining us
this thursday on the minimalist private
podcast that's a much deeper dive there
we roll up our sleeves get our hands
dirty and ryan i know we're gonna we're
gonna talk about some things that we're
embarrassed to talk about oh yeah man we
are definitely gonna talk about our most
embarrassing professional moments
because him and i both have some good
stories all right we'll do that
patreon.com the minimalist by the way
here's a testimonial from one of our
simpletons over there tori says
every private podcast so far has called
me out on something i've been doing as
i'm listening what a wonderful segment
thanks again minimalists well you're
welcome tori if you want to join us over
there
patreon.com the minimalist real quick
for right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists and this may i think this
ties in really well with uh with his
book and with people
pursuing a purpose or trying to find
some meaningful work
he often talks about
improving your skills taking your
talents and doing something with them
well i'm teaching my last writing class
of the year i only do this three or four
times a year and it almost always sells
out but you can go to
howtowritebetter.org
enrollment is closed right now but it
opens up on november 19th and 20th it's
the first hundred students so it may
even close the first day that it comes
out how's the writebetter.org and over
there you can even if you don't want to
take the class ryan's taking the class
endless taking the class
and we just revamped the whole thing we
redid all the videos we spent a week in
a separate studio filming with jordan no
more and podcast shawn was there we
brought other sean up who's an adjunct
professor for the class and we revamped
the entire class redid all the course
materials and but even if you don't want
to take the class you can download a
free ebook it's called 11 ways to
write better and you can find that over
at howtowritebetter.org
for added value this week there's a book
i've been reading i mentioned it early
on because there was that great line on
page 143 i think it was this is jonathan
franzen's new book it's called
crossroads and i gotta tell you
it's
i always thought freedom was like the
great gatsby of our generation that was
his book two books ago i think it came
out 2008 2009 somewhere around there and
it's just a magnificent masterpiece so
far i'm even enjoying this book more
this might be my favorite jonathan
franzen book but that line when he said
she became a different person in
rehearsals
entered a kind of
trance of not herselfness
every line in this is so carefully
considered which is amazing for like a
five or six hundred page book
he
does something
that
can only be accomplished i think through
either music or really great fiction
and he it's excavating the human
interior
the
insecurities the self-doubt
the
interpersonal relationships and what
that does to us emotionally
he captures it in this book
better than
i've ever seen it captured before man i
admire jonathan franzen um because he
takes about five years to write a book
right yeah sometimes it's as many as
nine yeah but uh yeah it's been quite a
few years since he's had another novel
come out
yeah just to show like how thoughtful he
is with his words man i mean he takes
his time to make it as beautiful as he
can yes you can tell every line is
deliberate which is
it's just so impressive it makes me like
want to just throw my hands up and say
how could anyone ever this we're talking
about a mozart of fiction makes you want
to quit writing it makes me
simultaneously want to quit writing and
write more
how beautiful is that yeah the book is
called crossroads we'll put a link to
that in the show notes it's by jonathan
franzen by the way we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week like how do
i bring myself to leave my job now
instead of sticking it out until that
perfect time to quit how do you
reconcile a job that you are good at but
it no longer aligns with your political
beliefs how do you know if your passion
is strong enough to become a career how
do you create a compelling purpose
statement plus a million more questions
for ken coleman and the minimalists and
if you want to hear all that check out
the minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com
the minimalists to subscribe and get
your personal link so that our weekly
private podcast plays in your favorite
podcast app you'll also gain immediate
access to hundreds of hours of private
archives recordings of live events
monthly ask the minimalist anything
sessions and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you subscribe today at patreon.com
the minimalists you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists come to one
of the minimalist live podcast shows
visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at the minimalists.com you'll
also receive our simple sunday email
newsletter for free and if you leave
here today with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it